on s'est posé la question de ce qu'on
pouvait faire pour participer pour aider
à l'effort global du pays face à cette
situation que l'on est en train de
traverser on s'est demandé ce que l'on
pouvait faire et on a constaté que
l'essentiel des garages en france
aujourd'hui soit fermées soit parce
qu'ils ont passé d'activité soit parce
qu'ils n'ont plus de pièces ce qui fait
que tous les personnels de santé les
personnes de la grande distribution et
toutes les personnes qui continuent à
travailler soit pour nous défendre
contre lui rue soit pour nous permettre
de continuer à vivre
ben non plus solution lorsqu'ils ont
besoin de quelqu'un pour dépanner ou
entretenir leur véhicule et donc du coup
on a décidé de mettre à disposition la
plateforme de manière complètement
gratuite de manière à permettre à toutes
ces personnes qui continuent à
travailler de trouver des solutions en
urgence proche de chez eux